are required to get the coveted vaccine
in order to sign up for the spring
semester enrollment opens today and
while most have already taken that step
others have refused some rallied even
against the mandate at unlv earlier
today and that is where we find hector
mejia joining us live on campus hector
what is the latest now with what's going
on here with the student vaccination
numbers
out of roughly 31 thousand or so
students here at unlv some 22 thousand
have received the coronavirus vaccine
and turned in their paperwork the
university expects that number to grow
as more students become eligible for
enrollment
college seniors and those with priority
registration can start registering for
spring classes today as long as they
submitted proof of covet vaccination or
have an approved medical or religious
exemption the requirement applies to all
nevada system of higher education
campuses including unlv where a group
protested the mandate i will never be
forced into getting this and i don't
care i don't care if they take away my
degree i cannot be an online student
because i am a geology student people
that feel like the vaccine should be
up to them which i agree with but i
think that they should realize too that
it's not only for themselves but for
others majority of students are actually
for it especially nursing students we
believe that the vaccination is the
safest way to return to normal
and so we're really encouraging everyone
to
get the vaccine dr chris heavy is
executive vp and provost at unlv he says
students can choose to take classes
online but not every degree is offered
virtually we're trying to grow that
number every semester but we definitely
do not commit that any student can
finish the degree that they're
interested on fully online
students can certainly complete some
degree fully online
and college staff members are also
required to have the coronavirus vaccine
but their hard deadline is december 1st
according to ensie as of last week 82
percent of employees here at unlv have
received their vaccine reporting from
unlv hector mejia live local now